the filmmaking on display
in this film is just phenomenal um it's
just a great movie that happens to star
batman can you sort of talk about that i
i 100 agree with you it's a brilliant
film and and
you know matt reeves is just one of
those directors who no matter what he
touches he brings such a kind everything
is considered it has intention it has
emotion it is powered by
great storytelling and it the the choice
of cinematography and production design
literally is seamless the marriage of
all of those things is seamless and i
think you know he is a definitely
one of the one of the greats and
world-class directors uh that that we
have at the moment i think he's he's
phenomenal because it all has such great
intent
i i absolutely agree um i'm so curious
because you know before filming began
there was a lot of rumors that matt
wanted to make possibly even a trilogy
did he ever talk to you about the
ultimate arc for
um you know for your character or is it
sort of like just movie by movie no no
no there was no there was no discussion
at all
[Music]
about
any sort of trilogy or anything uh it
was it was andy you know we we were in
post-production on war for the planet of
the apes when matt first started to talk
about this and and that that was a
possibility it was going to happen and
he just said look i really
i i think i have a role for you which
which i'd love you to play in um
you know i've seen you play emote the
emotions of of a character like caesar
and i've watched your face on screen and
then it finally disappear behind a
digital mask and i want to see those
kinds of emotions in in a character uh
in in the character in this movie so so
that was his
that was what we talked about and and
also the whole kind of notion of
you know surrogate parents
you know in in naughty complicated
complex relationships with with with uh
with chill with children slash teenagers
slash growing up to be adults um that
those those are the things that we we
talked about um that you know but no
trilogy mentions
sure um i've bro i've brought this up
with uh the rest of the cast and with
matt of course i loved greg frazier
cinematography um and i know we've
already talked about the filmmaking but
i have to specifically talk about a
cinematography because correct i've seen
the film twice now and i keep seeing new
things yeah and it's just a
cinematography is just so fantastic can
you talk about working with him and
maybe some of the shots that really
impressed you as a filmmaker yeah i mean
i i can't wait to see it again i've seen
i've seen it once and i'm so looking
forward to seeing it again but but i i
think
ma the combination of matt and greg
together and the way they danced around
each other and understood each other and
and the way that
that greg interpolated matt's vision i
mean matt is very specific about what he
he he sees and and he sees it when he's
writing you know it translates out of
what of the emotion of what he's writing
um but greg but greg was the the
lighting is just phenomenal and i don't
think i've ever seen i mean i i'm not i
can't i mean there are so many great
shots but what i will see is say is that
i've never seen gotham look so complete
and
um
sort of
its own thing and a character in in the
in the way that that that between them
they they and james chinlen's direct you
know production design the combination
of those three things i i i've never
seen gotham look so
so much of a character i think yeah i
completely agree i already got a rap i'm
just going to say congrats on the movie
and great to see you thanks man me too
you